worauf freust du dich worauf freust du
dich ich freue mich auf die ferien
ich freue mich auf die ferien
ich freue mich auf den urlaub
ich freue mich auf das wochenende ich
freue mich auf das wochenende
ich freue mich auf deinen besuch ich
freue mich auf deinen besuch
ich freue mich auf mein
ich freue mich auf meinen lohn
ich freue mich auf
geburtstag ich freue mich auf meinen
geburtstag
ich freue mich darauf dich zu treffen
ich freue mich darauf im restaurant zu
essen
worauf freut sich max worauf freut sich
max
er freut sich auf den final des
fußballspiels er freut sich auf den
final des fußballspiels er freut sich
auf seinen neuen job
er freut sich auf seinen neuen job
er freut sich darauf in die ferien zu
fliegen
worauf freut
worauf freut ihr euch
wir freuen uns auf unsere neue wohnung
wir freuen uns auf unsere hochzeit
wir freuen uns darauf zu heiraten
wir freuen uns auf die reise wir freuen
uns auf die reise
wir freuen uns auf die geburt unseres
kindes
worauf freuen sich die kinder worauf
freuen sich die kinder
sie freuen sich auf den spielplatz
sie freuen sich auf
geburtstag sie freuen sich auf ihren
geburtstag
sie freuen sich auf den ausflug
sie freuen sich darauf die geschenke
auszupacken
auszupacken worüber ärgerst du dich
worüber ärgerst du dich
ich ärgere mich über den stau
ich ärgere mich über den lärm
ich ärgere
über die hausaufgaben
ich ärgere mich über die hausaufgaben
[Musik]
ich ärgere mich darüber dass meine
nachbarn laut sind ich ärgere mich
darüber dass meine nachbarn laut sind
ich ärgere mich darüber dass ich eine
teure rechnung bezahlen muss ich ärgere
mich darüber dass sich eine teure
rechnung bezahlen muss darüber ärgert er
sich darüber ärgert er sich
er ärgert sich über seine schlechte note
er ärgert sich
der note
er ärgert sich über das schlechte wetter
er ärgert sich darüber dass er sein
zimmer aufräumen muss
zimmer aufräumen muss er ärgert sich
darüber dass er das geschirr abwaschen
muss
sich darüber dass er das geschirr
abwaschen muss
[Musik]
worüber regst du dich so auf worüber
regst du dich so auf ich rege mich über
das dumme tor gegen meine
fußballmannschaft auf ich rege mich über
das dumme tore gegen meine
den politiker im fernsehen auf
ich rege mich über den politiker im
fernsehen auf ich rege mich über die
umweltverschmutzung auf ich rege mich
über die umweltverschmutzung auf ich
rege mich darüber auf dass die politiker
nichts gegen den klimawandel unternehmen
ich rege mich darüber auf dass die
politiker nichts gegen den klimawandel
unternehmen
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal